nos piden dividir y simplificar y nos
dan una expresión radical dividida entre
otra expresión radical la clave aquí es
el hecho de que si se tiene la raíz de x
sobre la raíz de y esto es igual a la
raíz de x sobre y esta propiedad se
deriva de la propiedad de los exponentes
en la cual si se tiene algo elevado a
una potencia y al sacar la raíz cuadrada
estoy elevando a la potencia un medio
dividido entre otro algo que también
está elevado a la misma potencia eso lo
mismo que primero realizar la división y
posteriormente elevar a esa potencia
apliquemos eso aquí tenemos que esta
expresión es igual a la raíz principal
la raíz principal de 60 x cuadrada y
dividido entre 48 x y voy a trabajar por
principio de cuentas con los
coeficientes 60 sobre 48 esto lo podemos
simplificar vamos a sacarle doceava
vamos a dividir entre 12 estos términos
60 entre 12
es igual a 5 y 48 entre 12 es igual a 4
ahora podemos dividir el numerador y el
denominador entre x x cuadrada entre x
es igual a x mientras que x entre x es
igual a 1 lo que hagamos el numerador
hay que hacerlo en el denominador y con
eso ya hemos simplificado el cociente
por lo cual nuestra expresión quedó
igual a
la raíz la raíz principal de el
coeficiente quedó como cinco cuartos y
de hecho esto lo podría escribir de otra
manera pero no lo voy a dejar por lo
pronto así ya no tenemos nada en el
denominador excepto ese 4 y en el
numerador tenemos x porque por lo que
esto nos queda como la raíz de cinco
cuartos x 10 ahora podríamos dejarlo así
o aún podríamos sacar algo del radical
una posibilidad para hacer esto es que
lo escribiera de la siguiente manera
esto es igual a un cuarto que multiplica
a 5x y todo eso por supuesto dentro del
radical y esto es lo mismo que la raíz
principal de un cuarto por la raíz
principal de 5x para calcular la raíz
principal de un cuarto puedes considerar
que un cuarto es igual a un medio por un
medio o bien la expresión esto se puede
escribir como o bien podrías decir que
la raíz de un cuarto es un medio pues un
medio por un medio es exactamente un
cuarto o esto lo puedes escribir como la
raíz cuadrada
sobre la raíz cuadrada de 4 la raíz
cuadrada de 1 es 1 y la raíz cuadrada
principal de 4 es 2 verificamos lo que
habíamos dicho que este término de aquí
es igual a un medio y toda la expresión
resulta en un medio que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada principal a poner con el
mismo color la raíz cuadrada principal
de 5x y se ha simplificado totalmente la
expresión pues ya no hay cuadrados
perfectos así es que hemos terminado